you
now
okay so what i'd like to do is go ahead
and start the meeting here on the
foundation budget formula that we've
today is the last day that we will be
meeting as a subcommittee on that bill
seeing that we have to take action
uh on the
ninth and tenth and then by the tenth by
noon
so what we need to do today is that
there will be a report or recommendation
coming from this group right here
and what we want to do is look at
if we report
interim study what are some of the
things we'd like to see in interim study
address
uh so that's where i'd like to focus
today on some of those questions that
you know folks might be coming up with
and so let's open it up to that
type of discussion at this time uh we do
have mark here too did he have a
specific uh or is he as technical advice
technical support okay so
those sitting are our gallery of two if
you have any uh thing you want to you
know offer at any time just wave it in
okay
did anybody write down any concerns or
questions or things through maybe an
interim study
first of all maybe we ought to discuss
that is that where everybody here is
really and thinking we want to go with
this bill as interim study i see that
that that's a good point and and there
is a lot of good in it there's a lot of
questions in it
and so uh interim study i think is very
appropriate
and so that way we could keep rolling on
not through this subcommittee but
through the interim study
which would be fine
so
uh so you had uh
yeah i i mean i i think
i probably speak for everybody when i
say that uh ultimately
we're going to need examples of how this
is going to interpret be interpreted
into real life in each community and
you know take a look at
how the formula weighs out in terms of
the impact on the taxpayer but
i think that's that goes without saying
yeah i agree any education funding
you have to have a
spreadsheet or it's not going to get
voted on if sometimes i mean you're
voting for your constituents and if
you're going to lose money
you're not going to vote for it and
that's the way it works i'm sorry but
that's the way it works but
but i think what needs to be studied too
is freedom of study is the
adma formula thing there's a lot there
and i think that's something that can
you define that a little bit more ralph
well on page
four
okay for purpose of the weighted means
we respect each school district so i
think
that really needs to look at and maybe
with
how that's going to affect
okay
in terms of a spreadsheet you know the
first uh
number one that sue was addressing how
this weighs out in in terms of local
municipalities and communities
um and they and we know that
the house members will immediately want
to see where their particular town a b
or c is on this and and what the
difference is and or what our gain what
our loss might be
in terms of dollars
we have the spreadsheet that was
provided to us the other day by mark
is the lba also working on something or
how is that going to work
so um
so um mark and and mickey and i have
have talked about about this
and uh and i think given the uh the
direction that the bill's going what
mark has provided is a draft
and um and and as the as we move into
interim study and sort of leading from
what ralph was um was talking about
obviously the bill um has a um
well the bill has an eight year but the
the the really the the
developed con you know idea here is a
10-year phase-in
plan so so i i think it would make a lot
of sense for people to understand what
their towns would be seeing
as it's phased in over over a decade
and and the first year
which mark provided um
uh last week
is is terrific and there was a lot of i
mean you know mark talked about how how
you know this is a very involved very
comprehensive formula but in the first
year all the towns are there's a hold
harmless
so so you don't actually see
your your your impact your downside
impact
and um and i think it would be important
to see that over the over certainly the
the the 10-year period
and um and you know you've got that
you've got a five-year transition grant
that phases down and then you've got a
10-year
foundation opportunity budget that
transitions up
so so some towns may see a dip at the
beginning but then an increase later on
and uh uh
you know and i think there's there's
there's more work that we'll be able to
do during the interim study period to
illustrate that when you're at the first
step of the five-year phased uh process
down there with using the hold harmless
uh what what's the
the total cost for the hold harmless
verse
stables you know
stabilization i use this anonymous sorry
sure so so it's obviously more in the
the the most is in the first year
and so so the hold harmless that you can
see it in the in page two column i
it's
112 million dollars in the first year
and uh and that goes down to zero over
five years
in uh um in the aggregate over those
five years it's about 250 million
dollars
and the idea
would be that that that would come from
federal arpa dollars as other states are
using these in similar ways
and um and uh you know very good
question
now where do you where do you say that
was located
so that's in that's in the bill no no on
this phone oh sorry sorry on the
spreadsheet on the on the second page
that mark um handed out two of six
um
there were two that mark okay okay
that's my problem okay i see it now yeah
okay
make sure you get the i don't know what
uh
i might have more there were there are
um i've actually i've got the um mark
emailed me the pdfs i can
i can send those we could also you know
just get copies of one of these made
upstairs for you
yeah mark's got him so
well i mean we could take a few minutes
and just sort of you know bring ralph up
to speed
on that and
take about five minutes to do it yeah
well when he has that in front of him
yeah mark's got it
do you want uh
mark to do that or
mark magnanello administrator of the
office of school finance with the
department of education
so what we discussed last week and and
it is kind of hard to to look at this as
a from a cold read or just looking at
the bill and looking at the spreadsheet
and um
and it's it's telling if the total
weights and the total weights will be
multiplied by 6501
and that will equal
the annual foundation opportunity budget
so going through that process left to
right ratting up
similar to the existing formula we're
adding up all the adms so 180m
equals one weight so one it's a one for
one ratio there
um then we're adding up the fnr adms
similar to the existing formula except
instead of timesing them by a dollar
amount we're multiplying it by a weight
the weight is 1.49
sped adm uh this is the highest weight
um each sped adm is multiplied by
4.298
the weight
so
so just multiplying that 4.2 times 6501
yep
yeah the full weight of that 27k per
sped student is not felt um it's not
felt in uh ever because the 95 under the
bill the 95 is always there so it's
always going to be 95 percent of the 27
000 dollars
but yeah uh representative luna is
correct it's uh going to be uh uh
uh
what uh uh taken down to 70
then 74 and then progressively get right
and really important to remember too
that that while this is calculated on an
adm
basis
the the
the total
of all of that is is is really it's it's
a foundation opportunity budget for a
school district to educate all of its
students so it's not
it's not that you know david luno costs
the school district 28 000
student characteristics contribute this
to developing of
the entire foundation budget
yeah and i think we had conversations
last week about it being average cost
not particularly one particular student
it's it's the sum of all the students
weighted
equals up right you know an average uh
cost essentially right
so i i do it before we go on the other
sheet the spreadsheet i have a question
regarding this the weights here for
the adm sizes like 100 to 200 201 etc
etc
small district
that has 80 kids or 110 20 kids
including high school level kids
are the high school kids given a
weighted formula based upon the size of
the sending district or of the co-op
maybe that there are members of where
the you know the high school is located
is it
based upon the enrollment of the that
high school
or the co-op high school or the
individual district that's
they're coming from um
so
i'm using so i i'm not sure i understand
because this this can get um there's a
lot of different configurations on how
you can send your students and sometimes
you send your students to a co-op but
you're not part of the co-op but
sometimes you're a community that's part
of the co-op or you're tuitioning your
kids to a high school so it's not meant
to be
the way i calculated this and the way i
interpreted this and if this bill were
to become law the way i would uh
implement it would be admr across the
board so
if you're tuitioning your student in
it's going to be based on the sending
district purely not where they're
attending it's going to be purely based
on the district of financial
responsibility
uh so if you're a community part of a
cooperative
your cooperative would be
it's difficult here and i and there's a
lot of math that goes behind this but i
do a portion out let's let's use
where is an example k through 8 where
school district
9 through 12 john stark school district
so i do a portion out that i looked at
all the students in where
and the ones that went to uh k through
eight i looked at that particular
district which is a k-8 district and
looked at how many students are in that
district so it's not based on school
it's based on district um
then i looked at 9 through 12 and looked
at all the where students who are
students who live and where who are the
financial responsibility of the john
stark district
so it's always based on district of
financial responsibility not adma not
where the student's attending but what
what district is financially responsible
um which is essentially the sending
district
so if that helps yeah i understand that
my only
question was that the
cost of delivering the services at that
high score based upon
that high school not on what the sending
the sending district has to come up with
the tuition monies if they're a k-8
then they tuition out to
the receiving high school which might be
a high school that's
five times the size of the
smaller district the smaller district is
going to get so many dollars per
per youngster
which is probably more than they would
at that larger school on that weighted
formula
you bring up a good point and that could
be a challenge i think that's a policy
challenge in mechanical challenge with
this uh this bill
there could be some scenarios where
maybe the objective or intent of this
potential weight is not doing what it's
supposed to do there's a possibility for
that i'd have to look into the weeds as
far as is that occurring um is there a
mix match where maybe
the scenario you're describing
representative is creating a mix match
or uh
a weight that
the intent of it didn't include um
so yeah i have to dive into that further
that might be something the study
committee would definitely want to uh
take a peek and do right right if it's
creating mixed matches or technical
flaws with how the data is collected and
rolled up into the formula right right i
think the intent is um
is is that it's it's based on the um
the uh you know the the size of the
district that uh that the um or the uh
make sure you get this
the the size of the district that the
the
student is attending
so that if if hooksett sends its high
school kids
to pinkerton
then then
the the
cost the
the cost associated with those high
school kids is based on the pinkerton
size
okay that's right yes that's not how
this is being correct yeah so i i think
the intent
was but but we could i think that's this
is a really important thing
for for interim study make sure we
confirm that attempt and then make sure
that we've got the language that that
also uh
using hooksett as an example
not only do they send their kids to
pinkerton they also send their kids to
manchester central and to manchester
west as well
so uh
the size those three high schools are
going to be three different sizes
right
that that's fairly common throughout the
state and from many of the smaller
school districts the one i'm talking
about that just south of me
they send them down to thetford academy
they send them the muscoma they send
them to saint j they send them to
woodsville high school they send them to
oxbow over in vermont so there's five
different options available and the
and one of the challenges with
we talked a little bit about the
technical challenges is if you're a
we have the attendance
we don't have the idea may for pinkerton
i don't know if i i don't know if we
have the admit for pinkerton um we
certainly have the adma of students from
hooksett going into manchester um
we we have the adma for public schools
within the state we do not have the adma
for any school in massachusetts that a
ascending district might send their
students to or any or vermont or maine
for that matter um so there's situations
where you would be sending your student
to another school
um and we would not necessarily have
data on that so there could be a gap in
our data or or there could be a
workaround in the bill a workaround
could be devised in the bill if you
studied it
the other thing too is i think you're
talking about schools and so schools are
different than school districts so a lot
of these larger school districts if
we're talking about school level
uh if you're a school district north of
2000 adm uh you don't qualify for this
way but if we're now for talking school
like just uh you know manchester high
school uh manchester west et cetera
now we're talking about a lower
population lower adm so you might
trigger some of these weights if we're
now measuring at the school level so
another thing to think about and just to
file that conversation i know of one
district that's just north of myself
which has a wonderful dam on the
connecticut river
makes big bucks also has a large egg
producing farm there so they are a donor
town
but they're also sending their students
to a independent school
which has a high tuition cost
so by
the the swept would come into play where
they don't get to keep the excess
in this a funnels bath to five years
well no no because the the
the swept in in in uh in the bill yeah
is um is just like any other state tax
yeah so we're changing from what it is
to afford to do what they're doing with
their tuition program right now maybe
that's
that will be a concern from some place
for sure
and that happens to be the town of
monroe
that whole swept issue is going to be an
issue that's going to have to
have some answers to
i think with this study because i it is
going to cause
sort
disrupt people are there are going to be
communities that are not going to like
that and we have to have some good
defense for it i believe
am i out of line here saying this no
you're not because i come from a
community which would benefit from this
forum yes definitely however i
understand the complexities
and the constitutional issues associated
with where you're coming from so i think
something very important is to is to
recognize the constitutional issues with
regards to swept um what's uh what's
what's very good is that is that well
while we're
interim studying this we're doing it in
parallel with ways and means who's going
to be really
dedicating their their time on the
so that's the um still going through the
weights and yeah
one of the the ell fnr sped those are
those are data sets we're used to
dealing with
the the cooperative
or the the weights based on school
district size is something that um
we're still uh we we had some
conversations about that of course and
some of the technical aspects of that um
more going on with that weight than say
our other weights
the other weights include
column p there on that first excel
grade six through eight um gets a weight
of 1.42
grades 9 through 12 gets a weight of
0.42
so that's the weights the weights get
tallied up uh 450 000 weights
and then for each
municipality it's multiplied by
6501 and that gets you
your annual foundation opportunity
budget
unmodified unadjusted this is sort of
the raw the raw data from that
that calculation
so then we move on to the next excel tab
which has dollars associated with it
and so so so mark just just uh
i'm sorry to interrupt just but just a
sort of editorial uh interjection here
so when you get to column uh u
which which is the
the total of all those weights
multiplied by the base we haven't gotten
to the 95 percent and 70 percent part
but now you've basically got to the
dollars that were spent on on public
schools for fy 19
which was when this um
that was the data that was used because
that was the only complete data we that
that the
um that was available at the time all of
this was uh was done so so you've got to
that
2.92
um
number that's correct yeah i think um
that number is obviously always changing
but it's a pretty close approximation
give or take a few dozen million are
here or there but it's pretty right but
it's pretty close
a mark on the uh
grade level adm weights
um k-8 1.42 high school
.42
if you look at your funding formula
right now that we have in play
elementary costs
i believe are higher
than the junior high costs
i believe that's true and i have to look
at that more recently and i think i was
actually talking to some some of our
federal uh counterparts and um that is
not uh how it normally is most most
states have higher high school costs um
but yeah i think new hampshire's unique
in a sense our elementary schools for
one reason you look at a lot of the
elementary classrooms not maybe in
manchester
but
12-1 14-1
then you get up into the high school
where you get the block scheduling and
everything else and it closes it gets
into their where we're funding them at
at the um uh 30 to one level or or 25 to
30 level to one
so um
i i'd like to see some further work
from a policy perspective
whether we're really
giving whether we should be giving a
weight of some kind to
laurel uh elementary and and uh and up
through that those middle intermediate
level grades uh it seems to me they're
going to be there's no way to tall for
them
when in fact the facts now show that
they are costing more
than the upper levels
you rick on that too at the lower level
there is more
subs and assistance and what not in the
classroom
that increases the cost well you have
you know the prep periods new usually
it's a librarian or a
art teacher or a music teacher or pe
teacher comes in and you know that's how
we float around different days you get
different types of specials
um
it also parallels the negotiated
agreements uh it's re they're all it's
all related and that's how initially in
2008 the formula is set up based upon
the understanding
that um
so this is a thought elementary l is
uh so moving on to that second
second handout that one that
actually turns into the dollar
not just focusing on the weights but
focusing on the dollar amounts um column
c we're starting off where we left off
with the weights times 6 500 and 1
so that's the 2.9 billion there
and so
the next step is column d
which is first um
kind of right off the bat you apply 95
percent um so upside five percent
decrease to whatever the um that raw
number is that column c number
so that's called the uh and the bill
that's called the efficiency factor and
that's taken off
uh five percent taken off right away
then the other percentage that's applied
is the i believe it's called the
transition factor and so for fiscal year
24 it's 70 percent but as representative
luna was discussing um kind of i'd call
this a phase up it's going to increase
um
uh so it's 70 in 24 and i think under
the bill it's it's um
four percent in 25 and representative
lunos talked about
potentially
playing with that to make the phase in
smoother or flatter
you could make it quicker or shorter
depending on how you want to play with
that transition number that's going to
have a big impact on
the end results
so
if you apply the 95
then you apply the 70 percent now we're
from we're going from 2.9 billion down
to 1.9 billion
so this is called the adjusted annual
foundation opportunity budget so the 2.9
billion is really the foundation
opportunity budget and now we're
adjusting it
to bring it down to 1.9 billion and the
way to think about this similar to the
current formula is this is essentially
the state's obligation the states
the state is required to provide a cost
of inadequate education this is
essentially replacing that
thinking of this 1.9 billion as the cost
of inadequate education
so that's the benchmark the standard the
standard that the state will be held to
in this proposed bill
the next step is column e and f so
column e is a five dollars per thousand
tax rate um
applied to the equalized valuation
property of each municipality so
uh applying that five dollar rate each
if each community is able to raise
through a five dollar
five dollars per thousand tax rate
they're able to raise off their
equalized valuated property 1.1 billion
so this is kind of the local this is
called the local contribution
um
uh so basically we have a two point
billion standard the locals raise one
point
a 1.9 billion standard the locals raised
1.1 billion in local taxes and so
there's a delta there that delta is
essentially the state's obligation
but there's a little bit more math that
needs to occur
to actually define the minimum local
contribution we don't just use that five
dollars per thousand rate we look at
what is your five dollars per thousand
in equalized evaluated uh property
values um and then we also look at what
is your adjusted annual foundation
opportunity budget and we determine the
lesser of the two so that brings that
1.1 billion dollar number down to about
1 billion even
so
um similar process we're going to
similar to
just
stop right there and
have a question so we're going to do
five five dollars per per thousand here
and we know we're going to need around
12 point something 12.3 or whatever
total so that means the swept is going
to have to kick in somewhere along or
with the 7.2 7.5 whatever it might be
to round things out we're going to get
to that but we had talked once before
of
maybe there's two ways of doing this
one way would be to have the five per
thousand for everybody like this or just
to have the 12 point whatever is
necessary so so there's there's there's
two parts of this the five per thousand
is not swept
i get that that's the local education
tax
for the for the to to come up with the
the local um minimum contribution
and what mark's talking about here is
that in some country in some towns
we say another way in most towns
uh most cities and towns the five
dollars per thousand isn't going to get
you all the way to your foundation
opportunity budget you're going to need
support from the state
in some towns
it gets you
there and more and for those towns
you're
you don't have to raise any more locally
than your foundation opportunity budget
so so for uh you know for a town that
might have a lake or an ocean um those
towns would would have a local minimum
contribution of of uh less than five
because we're just trying to we're just
trying to take care of the foundation
opportunity budget right now
and um
and you know sort of like what we talked
about how um how in
in massachusetts which has
has begun its phase in of of a similar
program called the massachusetts chapter
70 school funding plan
um
towns like wellesley
they're all they're they're all set
where towns like lawrence um are working
just as hard as the towns like walter
but they don't have to work harder so
the state comes in and helps them get
the the rest of the way so so the
follow-up i have on that
on the five dollars per thousand is any
community
going to have to remem act remit back to
state excess
from the 5 000 no no
that comes later um
so the other 24 communities end up
having no not even not even talking
about that what comes
so the um yeah with the five dollars per
thousand none of that is sent to
to the state that is a local
contribution towards your foundation
opportunity budget if you can't hit your
budget with that that's where state
dollars come in if you do hit your
budget with that
you're you're fine
um
the
when we when we get when mark gets to
column k
you're going to see the state raises um
363 million dollars through the
statewide education property tax that
goes into the education trust fund the
same way
um
uh dollars from the business profits tax
business enterprise tax lottery
commission
and a smattering of other things that
are that are documented in the um in the
uh consolidated um
or comprehensive annual financial report
uh lists all those things out
so so that's um that's collected locally
the locals get to keep uh three percent
uh um
uh what do we call it a transaction cost
yep and uh and then the rest gets
remitted to the to the treasury um the
same way all other
taxes are collected in the state yeah i
think that's um
we're kind of we haven't even
we're still in the measuring phase at
this part of the formula we're we're
measuring baselines and top lines or
benchmarks essentially and floors um but
yeah eventually it's going to turn into
dollars but yeah i think it's helpful to
think about it this this before it turns
into dollars it's measuring benchmarks
and floors um but it's of course it's
going to turn into real dollars that
impacts funding but um
uh and i know swept is now um
yes we can have a conversation about
swept if you want to talk about
um uh all swept will be going to the
state uh uh 97 of swept will be going to
the education trust fund so that will be
um
some communities will be losing a swept
grant but they might be getting a
transition grant or a state opportunity
grant
any discussion on that
i'm sure i understand this now
so
we have two communities one that's
property rich community okay i don't
know
idyllica somewhere in the lakes region
and then we have depression which is
somewhere in the poor area okay but
but there's going to be equalized
valuation of the properties in both
towns
so
i know i asked this before but i forgot
the answer so the 2500 square foot house
on two acres in depression is going to
have the same equalized valuation as the
2500 square foot house in a delica no
the equalized valuation process is just
to um
um
is just to sync up uh standardized
assessment practices because you could
have one community that's really slow
with their assessments and that would be
unfair because it would artificially
yeah okay so depression has a house
valued at two hundred thousand dollars
five dollars per thousand five hundred
five times two hundred is the thousand
dollars in there in their tax
and the
idyllica has a
million dollar house okay so they're
going to collect that much
of a million what is it what is i lost
the number of the zeros there in my head
but you know what i'm saying so
depression gets money from the state
angelica keeps all that money
uh uh to go toward its schools yes so
yeah uh i think that's um we'll
we'll pick uh
well maybe i'll i'll look at alton alton
is kind of the first uh um
community on this list i liked idyllica
i thought that was kind of well you know
yeah i think what's important to to
recognize here is that is that um
equalized valuation all that means is
that is that
the fair market of a home in hopkins
you know
you know it's pretty you know pretty
close to fair market value in hopkinton
pretty close to fair market value in
wolfeboro and and uh and you know
because everybody has their own
assessing practices and the state now
has this fantastic um
system called mosaic
that that compares
transactions with
with with assessment rates and can can
come up with equalized valuation ratios
they put this in place in 2014
2015 following a a lawsuit by quote
donor towns back in the back in the day
that basically said hey how can you
compare a rate
in hillsborough with a rate in hopkinton
you can't we don't have any way of
equalizing the valuations and now we
have that in place
and
and so uh
so now you can actually
implement a
state property tax and have it be fair
just just yeah sorry yeah there you go i
i just so
that local contribution is just going to
stay in the town
for the schools the local contribution
if it's not enough
to meet what this bill says it should be
then we're going to pump some state
money in absolutely if it is enough then
they don't have to worry about anything
plus they can do their school
they can do more if they have it right
yeah with so with some of these towns
and i'll just i'll pick up pick on alton
because it's i know it's the prince tiny
but um
alton on column g you see the first zero
kind of for alton and what's what is
showing me with alton is
um alton's
adjusted annual foundation opportunity
budget their their benchmark the
standard that the state that must be
held to under this bill uh 7.8 million
but we look at how much they raise five
dollars per thousand uh
so they raised 10 million under that
rate so they already have the seven
million they need to provide that um
foundation opportunity budget under this
bill so they're not going to get any
state dollars okay and they also get to
keep they get to keep that yes
but i mean just because we're now and
we're going to get later in the formula
they don't get to keep swept or they get
to keep three percent of swept so that's
another
part of this thing
thank you that's i think
that's what i wanted to find out
but but under current swept law they're
keeping a lot more than three percent
yeah you know another way you can look
at the local contribution is is really
it put its fiscal capacity disparity
and uh and so if if through the five
dollars per thousand you don't have
enough to reach the um of the budget the
state comes in with the with the aid
because your fiscal capacity wasn't
sufficient to get there
for towns that that do have the capacity
then um then it's either less or
not existing and towns also have our
districts also have the option of
making their local
local tax higher than five dollars a
thousand if they want more
than the state is providing which is
great which most
will most schools probably want that
because this is like a base level that
we're coming up with so it depends some
some are going to um going to see that
that that this raises their um
um
that this improves their school budget
we say it that way
others might might say look we need to
we need to raise uh raise a little bit
more to uh to meet uh
what what we feel are the expectations
of our community but that's something
that's going to be debated on the uh on
the
school district meeting anyway right i
mean they do that anyway yeah okay thank
you
so so yeah just just going go continuing
to go on
we've got that starting from the
beginning again column d we got that
adjusted annual foundation opportunity
budget
knocked down by percentages
that will eventually phase up
1.9 billion we're looking at the local
contribution it's a billion so now that
state opportunity grant is the first
determination of funds under this uh a
grant first grant calculation
it's that delta between the uh
the benchmark which is the adjusted
annual foundation opportunity budget and
then the floor which is the minimum
local contribution so
the state comes in and picks up the
slack there and that produces 935
million
in state state grants
then we have
uh column h is the
is the measuring of the hold harmless
and there's some uh
don't know if we want to get two in the
weeds again with this but um there's a
the way statute says total education
grant in rsa 198 total education grant
doesn't actually mean the total
education grant
it means it means your grant minus
stabilization essentially um
so it's a little a little uh technical
there and that's something that the
study committee could probably want to
take a peek at
um but this only uh well
yeah something something to put in put
in the uh on your keep in mind
so fiscal year 23 is the benchmark
that's the hold harmless um
uh what you mean to be held harmless to
uh
so for if we look at something a town
like alton
they received 20 they're receiving zero
dollars from the state because their ev
their five dollar per thousand is so
high
that they're not
there's no gap to fill there under this
measurement
but they will be held harmless in a
sense that whatever money they are
getting from the state
as a total education grant in 23
they will get um as a transition grant
so you'll see there
um they got 2.7 million their total
education grant was 2.7 million in
fiscal year 23.
um
they're going to get 100 of the
difference there so the difference
between zero and 2.7 million is 2.7
million
and that transition grant is going to
slowly under this bill will slowly phase
out
to zero
so that's the the kind of phasing out
there's a phasing up and then there's
kind of the phasing out part of it
i think it's proposed under the bill i
think it's eight years but i know
representative lunas talked about
another configuration a 10-year
configuration for the for the phase in
for the ramp up
uh is what we're going to be uh is is
what i'd like the interim study
committee to to
work to look at look at
and then it's a five-year
phase down um mark i wanted to go back
to column h
which i think you've you've got there
right for comparison purposes to column
g yep
and so column h which is the the
current fy 23 total education grant
doesn't include 157 million in
stabilization and doesn't include the
approximately 30 million in
uh 16 million uh
oh that's right 16 million and hold hold
harmless
so
so that
would bring
the total
because obviously we don't have
stabilization in the new formula yep
but if you if you want to compare sort
of apples to apples
what the state opportunity grant is
and what the fy 23
current state grants which are the
adequacy grant plus stabilization plus
the the 15 million in in swept hold
harmless that comes to approximately 950
million dollars correct yeah i think
it's
954. but yes yeah yeah yeah we just
we're paying it out or we just budgeted
it so so yeah so we're we're showing
column g
that the grant actually goes down to 935
compared to 9
9 54.
um
and you would want to add in
to that number the the transition
uh there's the transition
and then there's also yeah it's hard to
know what the pairing apples and apples
the swept the three percent swept
retained right because you'd be
comparing one with a swipe without one
without response right and the
transition we're obviously looking at
for that to come from arpa funds and
that's one of the things we need to
study is the financial instrument that
would be necessary
to put something like that in place
and then the the three percent retained
um transaction
that's not necessarily a school district
correct it's yeah it's just it's um
you know i figured it needs to be
included when you're trying to do apples
to apples here um whether future
spreadsheets have it or not that's you
know
debatable right
i'm sorry
oh go ahead yeah i was just looking at
i think it's mewni is that bruce
or you could go over that mic right
there if you wanted to either way
you're right there at the table you know
to your right well you just grab it yeah
right
right yeah right let's grab any one of
yeah
yeah it goes red there you go got it for
the record my name is bruce canuer
i'm the supervisor of the municipal
bureau at department of revenue
my question was just to clarify does the
bill intend the three percent
to be
received by the municipality processing
the tax rates or for the school district
and there was that last comment that
made me ask this question the three
that's a that's a great question bruce i
i think the intent is that the um the
municipality um uh would would retain
that three percent remit 97 of the
collected swept to the to the department
and to the department of revenue
administration
and uh and they're basically using that
three percent as the the cost of
collection right processing the process
if you will right right and and uh
they don't have it doesn't have to go to
the school district but
right yeah and i think that's the the
reason why i felt like to have an
apples-to-apples comparison you needed
to have the swept on the spreadsheet but
really it doesn't belong on the
spreadsheet because it's a muni revenue
source but um
yeah so
something to think about
thank you but i think i think it was
good mark that you put swept and uh and
that on there as uh you know uh so that
you can you could you could see it um uh
but you're right it's not a it's not
necessarily a grant to the school
district
so
yeah we're so yeah we have the
transition grant um so yeah i think now
we're moving on to swept um so there's
that 363 million um
uh all but so 97 of that is going
straight to the education trust fund
so
10 is retained
so it's
you know the swept is uh it's just not
100 raised and retained locally it's 97
percent raised
sorry three percent raised and retained
locally
so that's probably the way to think
um and from there we get uh to column m
which is telling up the total the total
cost of hb 1680 for fiscal year 24. uh
can you i'm just trying to filter
through this still so three percent is
retained by the municipality yes the 97
percent then where is that going first
is it going to the
and stay in the municipality and they
have to reimburse it to the state or is
it going to the
state and
i'm just a little confused to how this
all works
uh chairman lada as i've read the bill
um
the funds would be remitted to the
department of revenue as any other state
tax
and then from there it would i believe
would end up with the department of
treasury
who i'm assuming they have the education
trust fund funds but it would be
processed through the department of
revenue
most likely would be in addition to the
new uh revenue the rim system since it
would be
coming in as a state tax probably
electronically from the
various municipalities
so the the municipality is basically the
collection agency yes sir and then it
filters up you know 97 percent just goes
okay
currently
um when the
swept tax is collected locally
it is um my understanding is i don't
work at a at municipal level anymore but
um each municipality has its agreement
with the local or regional school
districts for the um
transfer of education taxes to the
districts
generally an agreement where it's uh
spread out over the year and so the two
tax streams are
merged and payments are made monthly in
this case the the swept taxes would no
longer be part of that
municipality two district payment each
month instead they're coming
here to concord to go into the education
trust fund
at least that's how i've
understood
yeah
and i think that the
tricky part is and this is really tricky
for the
tricky for anyone but definitely tricky
for the public to understand is the the
swept
so although the swept is raised and
retained locally it's never leaving uh
the local political subdivision it's
going from uni to school district um and
sometimes community immune to department
within the muni when you're talking
about cities um
on our ledgers we are recording as if
363 million dollars came into the state
and we were recording on our ledgers as
if 363 million dollars went to the
school districts so that's when you when
you're doing a financial analysis you
have to kind of look not
what is literally happening to the
dollars but really what does the
financial ledgers tell us and that's why
it can get a little complicated here
when you talk about swap of course
yep ralph yeah i quit just looking at my
own town
which town you don't know littlefield
litchfield okay
if i look at
the swept
litfield now gets
about 2 million dollars
okay
so that's going to disappear you're only
going to get to keep 56 58 million 58
000 of that but the total
net change in p
is 1.2 million so actually
and we were getting eight i mean
1680 gives us eight we're getting 7.4
now so
looks like we're getting a net loss
because the swept we were getting 2
million
sorry yeah go ahead the the positive
there is you're getting 1.2 million more
um
so when you're you're your 2024 current
law includes 100 of the swept so that
correct
yeah and that's the tricky part is
because swept is raised and retained
locally but on our ledgers we're saying
it's 100 the state gave it to you
and and
what what what mark said uh is is
reflected on the the education trust
fund ledger in the kafir as well you can
see this the 363
uh put in there even though technically
it never runs through the treasury
currently so yeah our financial reports
will not i'm trying to think i guess
maybe yeah i guess they will change
because the three percent yeah i don't
know i can't speak to that actually i
don't know we'll do our financial
reports under this bill but
there'll be some
potentially some change
okay
have you walked through everything in
yeah that's the that's the uh we have
the column n is 24 current law we have
uh column m is the
proposed 24.
um i guess i'll just add another thing
and i know um
this is just fiscal year 24 so there's a
phase
i'll call i'm calling it phase up
because it's going to go up that's the
standard as you go from 70 percent of
your adjusted annual foundation
opportunity budget to 74 to 78 percent
that's going to increase the standard of
which the state is going to be obligated
to
so uh if if you hold ev constant it's
the
the cost is going to be more expensive
uh but ev uh uh could rise with that
uh if property values continue to go up
um we're talking 10 years here and i
think one of the conversations we were
having
last week was a 10-year analysis is
tough to do
it's the department's comfortable the
department's been historically
comfortable projecting out adm
even now with the pandemic it's a little
hard to do
a lot a lot of moving parts a lot of
variables there's a lot of variables in
this
um but if i were to do a 25 analysis
and i
you know i could do a 25 analysis uh 26
analysis 27 analysis but it's a it's a
matter of what you do with those
variables so what do you do with those
adm variables over a 10-year period what
do you do with the equalized valuation
variables over a 10-year period um that
would provide a clear picture on the
full scope of the bill of course
um
but i guess i haven't um
decided on or talked to my bosses at
least on you know what is the department
willing to to go out go on a limb and
say
this is what adm might look like 10
years from now this is what this bill
might look like so i'm a little hesitant
to
to do any analysis that would go 10
years out
just because i know it's it's it's
challenging
but it definitely is as you guys study
this as everyone the committee studies
this that's that needs to be
thought about of course that the tenure
the future uh the future very how the
variables will look in the future i
think that's important to consider
um
but it's you know it's obviously a
challenge
um
that's the and then i think um to talk a
little bit about where the the lba is at
um
i i did my analysis and i think it still
might be still be reviewing being
reviewed internally uh but i think it
will eventually get its way to the lba
and the lba will publish what they
publish
of course they'll um
i don't know what that will be
but the lba could um
we'll take a peek at this of course and
they'll give their their
publish their fn um
but other than that i think that's
that's all i wanted to share with the
committee out if there's any
other things you want me to go through
or discuss just
the phase up
which i don't know whether it's eight
years or ten years or
eight years here and you're thinking ten
but then the
the transition grant phase out is five
years
um
do those two
uh columns
have to be similar or you know like if
you're going to have a 10-year phase up
from the 70
percent
going up by four or four or four
or in in the phase
down in terms of the transitional grant
is going to be going quicker
so what's it going to look like in your
6 7 8 after the
phase down
so it
yeah that's interesting so i can't tell
you uh i mean representative luna has
like he has some longer term models that
he's looked at but as far as my looking
at it i have not done a six-year
analysis but i'm just doing i did do a
quick 25 analysis
and we were talking last week as far as
there's some transition talents but as
soon as you have a 70
adjustment as soon as you go to a 74
adjustment you eliminate transition
towns so
as you're ramping that up the need to
have transition towns is going to
disappear inherently so yeah i don't
know what it looks like as far as the
numbers but um as you're ramping up
phasing up um the need for transition
towns is going to slowly disappear and
disappear disappear
some of those bubble towns like bedford
might be a bubble bedford's kind of a
bubble town in 24 but they're not a
bubble town anymore in 25 and
and they'll be getting a larger state
grant and they'll be further removed
from being a transition town
as the ramp up occurs but there's some
towns that will um
uh always be transition towns until the
then what happens after it faces out and
then then they'll
they will not they'll they'll get their
three percent swept that's that's
essentially
and and you know i'm talking
theoretically i'm not like um i imagine
some towns here have really high five
dollar ev rates um
so unless they get a lot of kids in
their community and have a high
need for an annual foundation
opportunity budget
their ev is going to exceed that
you know we're talking about 240 towns
there's going to be some towns where
their ev's always going to exceed their
demand to educate at that uh at that
level
all right uh are there other now we've
just gone through this again for for
ralph and for us too you know it's i've
learned some as we've gone through the
second time probably the third time
might be the charm
just i'm looking over at the chartered
public schools and how that works and
it's referencing a section of law 198
41e
which i can't find in the book and i'm
wondering if that's just a typo
it's not a yellow book okay i was going
to look at
this
41e that's a new section in the uh in
the um
it's not in the yellow book no no it's a
new section in in 1680 is it the study
committee or yeah yeah it's the study
committee section yeah so it's a new
section
okay and and there was one other
question that i had i know this is
financing for
school districts
um and and we're treating charter
schools a little bit differently
is there any discussion or
what about
efas and things like that how that
and what money is going to follow the
child well be in accordance with your
your will it go like the charter schools
will it be that money that goes follows
the child is that what you're i don't
want to
i would have to think of that that's
that's something that this bill
contemplates needs needs additional
study
and um
and so that's what the um that's what
the section that you referred to does
that would apply to all per pupil um you
it's page 14. also may i think when
we're looking at like a 10-year plan i
think a lot of school districts and will
have a
10-year reduction
in school population so that that's
something also need to look at and how
that will decrease the amount of money
the schools are getting and they still
have bonds to pay off and that kind of
thing
yeah and that's uh i don't have charts
and graphs but i'll try to use my hands
but one of the things we're talking
about is that that standard
uh the benchmark that the state must
must achieve if we have declining
student populations that standard is
going to be cheaper and cheaper and
cheaper and then if ev rates go up it's
going to be the state grant is going to
decrease so yeah there's a lot of moving
parts a lot of variables to think about
okay are there any other questions
regarding this part right here the
spreadsheet and the costs associated
i i don't have a question but i do have
a comment and that is i'm gonna i'm
gonna keep beating this
drum
and that is that when we get to the
point where we're explaining how this
works to the public
we need to make sure
that we offer an explanation that people
are comfortable that there is
transparency and that they can actually
wrap their heads around why this is a
really good thing
and
whether or not that means that we you
know have to prepare a statement for
each community and model out what it's
i just think what we don't want to do is
leave it up to interpretation we want to
be able to put out information that
clearly states
where we're going and what the benefit
yeah i think on that i'm i'm a bottom
line person
and that's you know that's why i said
the spreadsheet how much and maybe for
10 years we need to see show that
but yeah because
i mean people are going to look at how
much is my losing or how much am i
gaining
and if i'm losing i don't want it if i'm
gaining i want it or if i stay the same
maybe that's okay
but you know so that's something yeah
like you said we need it needs to come
out we're going to get this much more
you know
but yep health for a town you got to get
this much less you know and
then you're in trouble
yeah and ralph in response to that i
mean i'll tell you that i you know i've
had conversations in uh
about uh
you know the problem that we have
funding education statewide and the fact
that we are these are all of new
hampshire's children these are not just
the children that live you know in
unfortunate circumstances we we own all
of these kids
and uh you know in to in credit to my
community a lot of those conversations
people have said
if i know where my money is going
then i'm willing to shell it out so you
know when we're looking at five dollars
per thousand or whatever i you know i
just i think that we need to be clear
that you know you're gonna you're gonna
write a check if it you know that it's
going to help grandma in the nursing
home you're going to write a check if
you know
that it's going to make a qualitative
difference to
students in manchester you know our our
neighbors
but i think we need to be you know we
just need to be upfront about
what the costs are and
our responsibility constitutionally to
the entire state of new hampshire's
children
and uh i can't you know i can't say that
enough that we are responsible for all
of them
right and i think for towns that
are
have a big problem where they're not
spending that much on schools now
because they're rich and whatnot they
won't have a problem but towns that are
heavily taxed
like litchfield and other towns that
don't have
other than residents that's pretty much
it because there's no roads for
businesses so they don't have an
industrial base
those towns you know hey
i want to see
how is it benefiting me because i'm
already paying a high amount of taxes
and for example have to compare to
bedford where you have an industry and
commercial and whatnot would help with
your tax base but we don't have any of
that in litfield and a lot of other
small towns even hollis for example but
they have they have another problem but
any but towns that are rich that won't
have a problem with what you're saying
the towns that aren't
however
ralph you can trust the fact that i will
hear a lot about this i don't care what
the per capita income is i will hear a
lot about the cost of education
but uh
yeah i mean
hey
if what we do for new hampshire we do
for all of us
all of us i mean manchester nashua the
larger cities litchfield i don't care
what community you're in
what we do for new hampshire we do for
the the other component in jumping away
from the spreadsheet that has always
been a concern to me and represent luno
has heard me say this before
is that we're
trying to develop a
an average cost per student and get this
performance outcome that we're looking
for
from our doe 25 form
the only form which we have that comes
in from a school district defining what
their expenses are
what their revenues are
and what their assets are
the
expenses
include
items which may not be part of an
adequate education
so in defining
what that
objective we have that performance
outcome yes we've said that oh yes we've
always rated in the top four or five
states in the country so we must be
doing something right in terms of
achievement
but i'm also concerned that there may be
include items included in there like
athletics which have nothing to do with
adequacy
or there may be some issues tied to
negotiated contracts labor agreements
which are just
different throughout this state
which may not be relative to
all of adequacy
so i've asked the department many times
is there any way we can break out what
is adequacy out of that doe form and
find out okay here's what the goal is
rather than
now what we've got is that we're going
to have in some cases some students are
going to be paid
you know we're going to receive or
districts for that student well over 37
thousand dollars if you include in that
sixty five hundred if you include the
four point two nine times the
the the sixty five hundred add it all
together
um and if they qualify in other areas
it's going to add up
so
so that that's that that's sort of a
sideways bar from with the doe i think
that needs to be broken down better for
us so we can see
what the cost of adequacy are
um and then the second part that i would
question is that i'm not necessarily
sold on the weighted factors
across the board for some of those items
in differentiated type a categories
the 4.29 i've hollered about that and
hollered about it
sure there are some students which are
probably needing more than that
but for a student who has a half hour
speech a week
why do they need that additional
you know um
twenty seven thousand dollars
not why don't we weight it according to
the handicapping category
and i meant to bring the sheet that i
have that there's a report that doe does
have on they know the numbers of kids
associated with various categories of
disability
so uh um
those are two areas that really to me an
interim study is going to have to
address
so no no just put
yeah
rick i think i think you're right um on
on both the uh the the um
the ability to um to to maybe look at a
at a more granularly defined um
classifications for special education
and and associate costs uh given the
severity and need i don't know
maybe we'd have this well right right
right now they're all in one it's all
because that's the data that we had from
the department um
because all for except one year
that uh that data was um was i'm
forgetting the term um
not not released in the uh
well because it probably was um we
probably didn't have all the 180
districts in probably was maybe maybe
when you asked for it it wasn't
completely finalized no no i think it
was from the the special education
classifications because some districts
have less most districts have less than
to hide someone's identity to hide out
yeah well you don't even you want you
want to even hide the
the department doesn't even produce the
the uh
the um the disaggregated counts
um
because for some districts it may only
be a one or two students and essentially
identify that that that student
you know and and the
the costs associated with that
particular student so so i think the
department has tended to provide
aggregated data so all student iep
counts um by district and those that go
over the um the
uh
what is it three and a half times and
ten times the average per pupil costs um
to quan to qualify for the categorical
special education
aid
but but so when this analysis was done
two years ago that's what that's the
data that that that we had to work with
without having a confidentiality
agreement in place with the department
to be able to work with confidential
data student specific data
so so from a transformer from a
from a
calculation standpoint i agree with rick
from a transparency standpoint i like
what was done that we worked with
publicly available data so that
everybody could see how how it was um
how it was used but it may not have the
level of specificity that that rick is
talking about here and i think that's
something that we should
um uh you know consider during during
interim study the other thing that i
think we're going to have to
address during interim study is um
is the the potential
to move away from uh free and reduced
price lunch to uh towards that the the
medicaid
and i forget if it was eligibility or
enrollment
data
as a
as a as a as a factor
and
and you know how we go about uh doing
doing that and
and in both those both those things
would play into the um the adm formula
uh on um on page four
so i i absolutely agree um well those
are the i agree on the medicaid too that
that's uh umberger's looking at right
now and i think that's you know an
important thing to look at is there
another way of gathering poverty
information
um
and you know i understand that much of
what was done we were limited by the
department and what kind of information
was available at the department we know
what attendance is we know all those
categories
uh and we know achievement but uh uh
there there there are some categories
which just they don't don't collect the
information you know i'd be interested
in a thing like geographically isolated
schools the cost of doing business in
those schools is extremely high you
can't afford a contracted service and
speech or a physical therapy you have to
draw it out of concord and nobody's
paying that transportation other than
the local district to get that
contracted service up
so uh there are formulas throughout this
country that do give some weight to to
schools like that we're not quite the
same as maine where you have
geographically isolated schools out in
islands
and and you have to transport different
ways that's obviously a horrendous cost
but we do have you know if you're
sitting here in concord today
and drive up north you're going to find
the price of a gallon of gasoline a
whole lot different uh there than you
are here it's going to be much more
expensive
even though schools may get it on the
government buy at the local dot
shed but they're they're the cost of
doing this for everything else is very
high
so
just you know
we can't do much about that we've tried
geographically isolated legislation in
the past
small schools
and then of course i've had certain
senators say well we're going to just do
the same thing down in manchester we're
going to make all small schools so we
so
i don't know if you can win on any of
that
guess those were my my concern areas
that primarily the doe 25 and the wayne
categories especially for the sped
so yeah and and and i think what
you know again before before i think we
if we're going to be
looking at weights and remember the
weights are basically to uh you know to
basically have a um
have a a formula approach to arriving at
those foundation opportunity budgets
which were calculated using a
statistical analysis so that we didn't
have to do it
so there that's like the balloon you
push it in here it comes out over here
no no it's it's not so the weight the
statistical analysis actually gives you
the foundation opportunity the budgets
the weights are just a way of arriving
at those numbers in a in a simple
algebraic
method
and as opposed to a real complicated
analysis so so if you if you take
exception with the weights
you're basically taking exception with
the the foundation opportunity budgets
that were calculated from a statistical
method because if you change the weights
now you're departing from
from
you know from from what was what was
estimated to be the budget for a school
district to provide an adequate
education
uh which is defined in the bill
for uh for students to be able to
achieve a statewide um uh outcome i
understand that yeah yeah my concern
though is that in looking at the weights
and you're we're talking about something
a little bit different than the actual
weight of you know 4.29 uh we're talking
about
if in fact it's 1.2 here and 4.29 here
and all over somewhere along the way
we've got to come out with that
foundational budget and when you start
messing away here you're going to impact
the weight somewhere else
that's and and so
i'm concerned that by having a weight so
high and special i as a superintendent
say i know how to make some money here
you know the the kids which are on
monitor or the kids that are the 15
minutes per week i'm going to have more
of them i'm going to have my speech
pathologists and speech pathologists
don't like to do this they don't like to
identify
so early in the game before
you know the muscle development has
really been developed
everybody in this state comes in with an
r problem
sort of linked with massachusetts but
you could identify this stuff and you
could really jack up the revenues coming
in your district very quickly
by just identifying 10 or 20 more kids
which have the speech issues
and
it's good this is going to happen you
know i was talking to a daughter of mine
who is a speech pathologist in another
state
and she indicated today to me as i'm
driving down the road that her speech
loads increased over 200 percent since
this pandemic
based upon
well you know you're not seeing the
mouth characteristics the kids aren't
mimicking what the teacher mullen over
here is teaching or teacher porter and
so it is going to create
a high demand for some of these services
and the costs are going to go up
yeah but on the other hand
a child might only be seeing a speech
and language pathologist once a week
but then you've got the kid who has the
physical therapy the occupational
therapy the speech and language therapy
the reading assistants the math
assistants those kids
cost more than 27 000 so doesn't it
equal itself out i mean not all
special needs kids are just getting one
small service and not all of them are
getting every service i think we're
playing a mathematics game here and i'd
have to see how this all filters out in
a district one way or the other but i
think it's worthy there are states which
are doing different weights for
different uh
you know handicapping conditions
uh we haven't i don't think we got there
because we just couldn't get the
information out of the oe
so so rick i think i'm getting a better
uh
sense of what you're talking about here
too you rather than having one large
weight which could result in inflated
iep counts yeah um have have more more
um
i don't know what the term it's
classification specific weights um
tied to specific student needs so that
if um
if if some of the counts were were going
to be inflated they probably would would
not
not impact the total that much as
something that
was used to capture everything yeah
there's a lot of policy and programmatic
issues associated with speech therapists
working in a hospital with a an older
individual that's had a stroke and
trying to regain some speech
versus a child that's dealing with ours
a whole lot more time
is spent in one place than the other i
know there might be a balance in terms
of well i have other two kids and we're
not talking cat eight here or a
speciality we've got to make sure that
we're not looking those categorical
areas like this and and building aid and
and
other areas that we we have special ctes
etc
these are not part of this although
there have been efforts on the part of
myself and another member that was part
of that commission to try integrate the
cost of cte into this
so
there has to be a way
because the 4.29 and the
total number of students that we have
yields a sum
there has to be a way to have sort of
sub-categories or sub-weights within
that
dedicated amount not that that amount
isn't going to be fluid we know it will
be because kids come and go but
i would think that it can be done that
if you you know met the qua
characteristics of three of the sub
categories then you would be weighted
one way
if you only met the characteristics of
one then you would be weighted another
way is that what you're talking about
rick
yeah and and if if you come out and you
see a savings there i'm not saying you
gotta ruin the whole foundation formula
you could also be then saying well maybe
we could jack up those uh
factors in the weights for a different
size of schools
i'm not convinced that we're really
attacking the the small small school the
way we should uh the cost of doing
business for a school that's under 100
kids is huge
it's huge and you you try to say to that
community well you you should be sending
your kids 10 miles down the road oh no
the culture of our community is this and
this is what we want
and the students will be here they know
each other we know them parents are
welcome in this school etc etc that's
culture
and you can't change new hampshire it's
local control first that shared
responsibility we talk about all the
time
but i would i would consider you know if
we were able to do something over here
so it didn't be
capture the dollars here and move it
over there where everybody enjoys part
of that foundation uh
cost our money that we were able to save
maybe in one category so you're not
changing anything
uh at the total at the end you're you're
changing within
right right um but but i i i think what
what this will do rick what you're
suggesting is
it's going to
provide i think a more
detailed and a more specific
foundation opportunity budget for every
school district depending upon the
number of students they have in certain
need areas
and
obviously the more
the more we understand about the need
areas
um and
how
those that ties into the costs
then uh then we can arrive i think at
even more accurate foundation
opportunity budgets uh as long as the
data is available
and uh yeah
well that's what we should interim study
is what we we do that with yeah
yeah
are there any other areas that you know
we we asked everybody to come in with a
couple suggestions is where you know we
might incorporate into a committee
report that the interim study you know
try to drive at
um
are there any other areas that we should
be talking about today to include in
that report
just um
concerns about ferpa and
whether or not
student confidentiality is compromised
if you've got
those tiny little towns that are out in
the middle of nowhere and they have
three special ed kids and one of them
costs 285 000
you know what i mean uh
how
how protected can the data be
that we receive so that it's
it
it protects the process protects
we've we've had that discussion on many
different types of legislation to come
through
so on the constitutionality part of this
dave
where we got claremont and londonderry
and all saying some very specific things
to us
does this
meet the mark
and
how did massachusetts get through it
without having
what they
and i i know that's an original question
so so well i think it's uh i think it's
an equi i think it's certainly a
question for um
for people with uh with legal
backgrounds and uh representative ames
actually was uh was part of the
legal team i think down in massachusetts
with the department and i forgot the
name of the case but he has talked about
it a couple of times
um as being one of those sort of
fundamental cases in terms of uh shaping
um school funding in massachusetts
and um the um uh again this is this is
coming from
from uh people that that know much more
about this than than i do
but um
but uh given the the similarities in me
in our both our state's constitutional
requirement to constitutional
obligations
for um for funding education
massachusetts has adopted um
a um
uh you know a pla
a plan the massachusetts chapter 70 plan
which which does direct uh state dollars
to where they're to where they're needed
and that's uh fundamentally what uh what
we're doing here in 1680 uh as well and
um and right now you know as we all know
the uh the the amount
essentially what what manchester gets
from the state is the same thing that
newcastle gets from the state um and
obviously manchester's access to
resources and
pittsfield's access to resources and new
ki and litchfield's access to resources
and hopkinton's access to resources and
hillsboroughs and bedfords and haverhill
and newcastles are all different and um
and so um so new hampshire's never seen
a plan like like this before
and uh
and uh you know i and i i'm i'm really
you know
uh grateful that i think we've got the
opportunity to to move this into interim
study so that we can take a closer uh
look at it and and and how it could be
rolled out
in new hampshire um what sort of
constitutional considerations our courts
might uh might you know uh
consider when when when uh when fought
when decisions start to come down
i don't know a year from now a year and
a half from now so there's two things
with uh what's gone on with our our
court cases which we've heard here
in in the past
i'll read them the new hampshire uh
supreme court held that the state must
bear full cost of funding
the opportunity for an adequate
going on the court further stated that
taxes levied to fund this obligation
must be uniform in rate and equal in
valuation throughout new hampshire
and lastly none of the financial burden
for adequacy funding can be shifted to
local district districts regardless of
wealth or need
so do we meet those three concerns in in
this yeah i think i think we do meet uh
meet those concerns primarily because
the
the state's not never seen a plan uh
like this like this before
and um and you know and i think as we as
we you know look at modeling this
over the transition period and not just
over you know at year one but over over
over a decade um seeing what that does
uh in fact for um for
local property tax rates and how it
closes the right right now they range
from what do we say two dollars and
fifty cents up to about twenty five
dollars per thousand the local education
property tax
so so plans like this
pull pull that pull that i mean it
doesn't make it the same
you know this doesn't this is this is
not saying
that
that that every town and city no matter
where you are
is going to have a a local education tax
of 12 dollars per thousand
this is not saying
saying that
um uh
this is saying that um that
you know getting towards your foundation
opportunity budget you need to kick in
five dollars per thousand the state gets
you the rest of the way and if you want
to go over and above that that's on you
um but that foundation opportunity
budget is uh is defined
as as what it would cost for a district
uh to deliver an adequate education to
all of its students uh which is a
statewide um outcome so that the average
student in every district can can
really come as close to you know
approach the statewide performance which
is among the best in the country in fact
it was just in
i think i saw a news release the other
day
said new hampshire was top five or top
six which is right around where where
we've been saying it is right behind
um you know massachusetts and and uh
yeah so
so you know we've got great student
outcomes uh we just don't have them
everywhere and uh and so this is this is
closing those opportunity gaps
um uh
on that point and i mentioned it to the
other day when we try to get research
from massachusetts where they've gone to
into a and
operate with a
similar foundation type formula
have they been able to close those
opportunity gaps between our subsets of
students
by all those uh cultural type uh you
know categories right so they they
not just physical categories as well
you know have they you know we
in our present scheme of things we're
not closing those gaps
they're getting larger
we want to see something we can close it
is massachusetts closing is the question
is that what we can get from their
research well uh if if they've started
uh getting that data then i think we
should be able to take a look at them
because because they're they're only at
the beginning of their ramp um right now
and and you know and it's going to take
years for data to uh to start to to come
out
as a result of
improved
you know
yeah making sure that schools have
access to the resources they need it's
going to take a while and even even with
this
even with this
we're saying that it would take new
hampshire a decade
before
before we're providing manchester with a
foundation opportunity budget and access
to the resources that they would need
to
to compete with
so that their students could perform at
a comparable level to places like
bedford
right next door right next door
and we're going to say manchester kids
you're going to need to wait 10 years
before you have that before your before
those opportunity gaps are closed before
those disparities
um
are addressed
you know
we've we've been at this
longer than any of us i mean
right
so 40 years since the um since the
the last time this was studied in great
detail with a you know with with
professionals from outside so that um
you know 1982
[Music]
formula so so it's been 40 years where
we're on this it better not take another
40 years
and uh and hopefully conval will
will will put the state in a position
where they won't let the state take
another 40 years on it but at the same
time
it takes time for any systems to be you
know school districts
and i'm talking sort of engineering
terms um to respond to resources so so
uh so throttling up can't just be done
like that
it needs to be done in a way where
school districts can respond to uh to
the the the additional resources just
and i think doing it over a decade is a
responsible and practical way to clarify
another point i think if if
the state tries to sell a package like
this
i don't think we can should sell the
package that this will make things
absolutely better it will contribute
but there's a lot of non-funding
variables
in every school in every community
where
achievement maybe is more valued over in
your district than that district or or
the aspiration of the family is more
here the involvement the family is more
here than over here the quality of the
spanish teacher is better in this one
than over that where you get an a if you
bring brownies in the class and spanish
teacher can't teach spanish
my my kids were in a class like that not
in this state but in another state but
that type of thing happens
throughout and we can't deny it
so that we'll see change and growth
it would
result of not just
the funding package but also of the
leadership and the supervision and the
instructional know-how in the classroom
and it means accountability we talked
about
that accountability has to ensure that
you're getting the top-notch people in
that classroom
and it's also we're not a factory we're
not producing widgets we can't make
you can't just retool the machine
and pop out perfection every time
because they're people we're dealing
with we're kids and teachers and
human beings that are in fact that are
make mistakes sometimes but the goal is
to help everybody do the absolute best
that they possibly can
and even the playing field as much as we
we're closing in on the noon hour
i think we've you know hammered here do
we have any other questions for the
none
i'll just
rory either department that's correct um
i just want to say i did look up
last week we did talk about manchester
nashua and i did dig into that a little
bit nashua
looking at 24 nashville is getting a
very small grant manchester's getting a
large one um so we're kind of
interesting to look out and this kind of
shows you how
the current adequacy formula works but
also how this formula would work it's
all relative to how many students you
have the demographics of the students
and then your property values so nashua
and manchester actually have very
similar property values 64 the five
dollar tax
brings in 64 million for manchester 63
million
for nashua so pretty much the same
minimum contribution there but when you
look at manchester manchester we know as
a larger city than nashua
they have two thousand more kids two
thousand more f r kids 650 more sped
kids so when you have that that floor
that five dollar ev
um
uh five dollar per thousand but you add
in the tallying up all the weights of
manchester's kids you get a higher
number so a higher state opportunity
grant so just um looking into the data i
just thought i'd share that
but for for nashua um we know that that
as as that ramps over over the years you
know and it will ramp for manchester too
but um but uh nashua will uh we'll see
we'll we'll see that
you know over the over the decade round
yep absolutely uh yeah so the ramp up um
their state opportunity grant holding ev
constant their state opportunity grant
uh will increase um just yeah just
manchester nashua although there are two
biggest cities they have
some different demographic issues or
different
student populations
but same ev so kind of interesting
yeah i thank you for
looking at that for us we brought that
you want a motion
well we ought to make a motion as to
for to present to the
the larger committee
we did so show hands here i think we're
all so would you like to make a motion i
i would make a motion that that uh that
we we recommend 1680 for interim study
and um and while while certainly we can
we can study numerous numerous areas um
in this bill as well as as well as
considerations that for things that
could go into the bill
that um that we
we you know
we look at
uh student needs driven costs we look at
the state property tax
uh we look at how the impact of court
decisions and the conval lawsuit might
impact
our our obligations we look at the
transition and rap and we look at um at
uh making sure that uh districts have
access to the resources they need
okay yes there and you know is there a
second
okay great so we have a motion made by
representing luna second by
representative boom i'd also like to tag
in on that that with interim study we
won't be starting the interim study
until
when the governor signs this or when
it's approved by both chambers i'd like
to also sort of see an attachment that
we recommended this committee continue
moving forward and active so that we can
you know continue maybe to get research
and uh materials available so that when
that interim study does start the
materials are here we're not going to
lose time yeah
absolutely agree yeah okay
so no problem with that
okay so just add that into this motion
and
uh all in favor
aye aye
thank you it's unanimous
so we'll move forward that report um i
think on the ninth it is
wednesday
okay
thank you very much uh thank you much
for your work today and thanks for the
agencies that came in departments came
in appreciate it
it's a conversation that will go on and
on and hopefully with some resolution
thank you
it's interesting um
rick that i found an old newspaper
article from when my late husband
was a child so that has to be back in
the 1950s that my late mother-in-law
wrote a letter to the editor
talking about the lack of school funding
in the state of new hampshire and why it
was important that we that we support
our schools with with a good funding
mechanism so it's a long time that this
has been going on well it's like the
commissioner report of education back
then it wasn't called education but in
the 1880s the commissioner made a report
there's nothing more important than the
quality of the schools we're teaching in
and we have some schools now out there
that are over 50 years old 60 years old
and had a few renovations but we're
still having problems with
like you said the other day lead
drinking water letting the water we're
having problems with the heating units
that have tubes and that could probably
heat the queen mary
um
we need some things changed and and the
schoolhouse is extremely par i believe
what you said there yeah the new school
in hillsboro is 25 years old
[Laughter]
shall we start comparing what we have in
woodsville to we had to tear the old
shack down
elementary school was the high school
built in 1920. so let's arrive it's
there
yeah
it's certainly an important topic it's
our future education is so let's
try to get this motion through and um
keep working on it
right
thank you very much we are adjourned
jennifer you're going to need some
reports here i'll have to write some
my thinking was that
you